now let's remind you of little nas x and
his headline grabbing performance of
montero call me by your name at sunday
night's bt awards
everything
[Applause]
online with multiple outlets stating
that the pop star pushed the envelope
ending his ancient egyptian themed
performance with a long kiss
with one of his male dancers yes and of
course there are some stars speaking out
about it as well
notably though adam lambert who recalled
experiencing
some serious repercussions after
similarly kissing his male keyboard
player while performing at the 2009
american music awards
i thought it was hot lambert told
billboard adding
i think he is definitely like the gay
pop star that is 2021
he's bold he's controversial he's
pushing boundaries
that's what we want our pop stars to do
it's just taking this long to have it be
a gay one
yeah contin excuse me continuing on
about the controversy surrounding his
own same-sex onstage kiss lambert said i
was pulled off of abc for a little while
they were freaked out they had christian
parent groups writing in
the sensors were freaked out the thing i
found so funny was like sensors
it's a kiss when was that indecent
lambert later spoke about the
controversy surrounding his performance
during an episode of visible
out on television i get on a plane to
new york because the next morning i was
supposed to be on good morning america
to perform the song and
i get a call after landing that i've
been removed from good morning america
so quickly my team shuffles around and
puts me on a different morning show on a
different network
and they said the only way we're gonna
put you on there is we have to have a
sit-down interview about the performance
now that you have had time to think
about the children your child
fans do you do you feel that you need to
apologize to them
we've seen lots of sexualized
performances throughout the last 20
years on
television on award shows wearing
assless traps
doing a sexual dance making out or
grabbing
what i was trying to say was how is me
doing one of these things
different than the other and to me i was
like this is i'm being targeted because
i'm gay
do you think it's because you're male or
do you think it's because you're gay
both
i think it's a double whammy and i
remember saying
look you know a couple years ago i saw
madonna kiss
britney spears and christina aguilera on
the vmas
and they show a clip of madonna and
britney
lip-locked but when they cut to my
picture
it's blurred out because what because
it's indecent or obscene
and then they went to commercial and i
remember looking at the reporter and
went
you just proved my point
oh yes and speaking of that kiss between
madonna and britney spears
the material girl is coming under fire
following a post she made about little
nas x's recent performance
posting a side-by-side image to her
instagram stories
madonna showed a photo of her 2003 vma
performance alongside a photo of little
na's ex at the 2021 bt awards
adding the hashtag did it first
underneath the two images
yeah so of course as the image made the
rounds fans started voicing their
displeasure
that madonna chose to center herself in
lil na's x's moment
reached out to madonna's rep for her
reaction but haven't heard back
so what do you think everybody was adam
treated unfairly
back in 2009 and do you agree with
little non-access fans that madonna
should step aside and let the pop star
have his moments
oh my gosh i just feel so badly for adam
lambert i mean he did something
that opened the doors in a lot of ways
for little nas x he wasn't treated
fairly he was treated very poorly
um and in honesty i would really like
for adam lambert and little na's ex now
to make a song together like that would
be
in a hit let it be like something so
incredible let it go number one
redeem that for adam because adam is so
incredibly talented
and just what we just watched what he
had to go through
it was completely a double standard and
now seeing madonna put that side by side
shot
um i find that to be here's the thing
when i first saw madonna put the thing
and put
you know did it first my first
assumption was soulja boy right now
has this fun challenge on instagram like
i was the first rapper to
you know and obviously we just saw what
courtney love did recently like twinning
like i did it first
there's a lot of that with olivia
rodrigo so there's a lot of that going
on
with the legends kind of speaking out i
thought it was in humor
because i assumed madonna and little
na's ex are friends um
so that is my assumption of things if
it's not humor
i think that is not the best example
obviously madonna is kissing
christina aguilera and britney spears
the three of them are
you know sexualized overly sexualized
females and there is a double standard
in media um
gay men don't get the same respect um at
these award shows and during these
performances as
as women do it's so unfair and it's so
wrong but i don't think it's a
comparison i think she did it
artistically first
but you can't you can't compare at all
no and i i think the intention behind
each
was different i think the intention
behind each thing was different
madonna has um i don't want to take away
that moment for people that found that
moment liberating for themselves
but i'm not entirely sure that that was
the intention of the moment when it was
planned and put on stage if you know
what i mean you're watching that footage
of adam lambert and
in both those interviews in the recent
one you can see how raw it still is for
him
to feel that and to feel how much the
backlash against
his expression um which he clearly
thought was like listen it's 2009.
we're here we've made progress we're
making progress this is something that i
can do
right and yeah and then like the
backlash that he got
him being cornered about it happened to
answer
like really unfair questions about it
and how it very likely derailed
um a lot of the momentum he had at the
time
absolutely you know like you said such a
talented performer
in every dimension of it not just his
amazing voice but just knows how to
how to be on stage um for all intents
and purposes should have been bigger
than
uh than he has been in the last however
many years right and it's moments like
that
from people making decisions based on um
what like the sensors based on reactions
from overly conservative groups
that can do that to an artist so yeah
you can really see that when you watch
those interviews with them
yeah lots of comments carla says this is
a discussion about lgbtq plus artists
and not anyone else and we should listen
lw says madonna is the
blueprint maybe if they did something
new there wouldn't be a comparison
um tony says given his talent adam
should be a bigger star than he is
um yazzy says adam was treated unfairly
some parents really want celebrities to
raise their kids
i mean thank you like
the parents getting offended like these
are award shows why not
like we have pvr and all these things
why not watch the show
and decide what you want your child to
consume
why don't why isn't there like why do we
just like put kids watching anything
live and assume like what no it doesn't
work like that
even super bowls we've seen even super
bowls things parents getting so
up in arms about oh my kid watches well
maybe your kids shouldn't be watching
live tv with you because
like they're not responsible for your
kids yeah and and if
i i don't know like i think my take on
that like
is if you're prepared to have them watch
something where you know something can
happen like we've watched award shows
over the years and you know what happens
yeah with
performances with people trying to push
the envelope with people being
hypersexualized
if you're not prepared to have that
conversation with your kids and they
don't need to
watch it maybe right no like or be
prepared to have the conversation with
them about what that is
when you do watch it with them um and to
adam's point when he was
you know speaking about um uh award
shows performances like the assless
chaps like all of
everything that we've seen in those
shows i i agree with him 100
like all those things were already out
there how
radically different would it have been
for him to express his thing
like i don't know i i i agree with
everybody on chat here
it's like he was he they did him dirty
100
they did him so dirty uh lindsey race
had something that i really liked
madonna in regards to madonna girls
kissing has
always been more accepted than guys
kissing it's not the same thing in
society's eyes
it's totally true it's so frustrating to
me
well that's that's that's one of the
things that comes up immediately when he
makes that point about
here's that shot of madonna brittany and
then here's that shot of me being
blurred
it's all about clearly to me it was all
about like the straight male perspective
on those moments what do we watch and
what don't we get to watch that's
that's what that was back there so yeah
totally unfair totally unfair